antoine bonjour alors depuis hier la
chancelière allemande demande des
comptes à la russie au sujet de cet
empoisonnement présumé d'alexei navalni
comment ont réagi les autorités russes
mais alors le porte parole du kremlin
dimitri peskov s'était dans un premier
temps l'entente du tout à leur exprimer
en rappelant qu'avant son transfert en
allemagne alexeï navalni avait subi de
très nombreux tests et qu'aucune
substance toxique n'avait été découverte
dans l'organisme de l'opposant politique
russe et dimitri peskov s'est de nouveau
exprimé sur le sujet aujourd'hui il dit
ne voir aucune raison à ce que la russie
à ce que l'état russe soit accusé de la
dégradation de l'état de santé de
d'alexei la vanille je vous propose
d'écouter dimitri peskov
je serai prudent en parlant
d'accusations lancées contre la russie
il n'y a pas d'accusation il n'y a
aucune raison pour que de telles
accusations soient formulées et nous
sommes réticents à accepter des
accusations à cet égard quant au fond de
la question
le parquet général russe a envoyé une
demande des du 10 hier à berlin
[Musique]
elle a été reçue par la partie allemande
il n'y a pas encore eu de réponse hier
lors d'une conversation ministère des
affaires étrangères notre ambassadeur à
berlin n'a pas non plus reçu
d'informations spécifiques sur les
résultats des recherches menées par les
spécialistes allemands qui leur ont
permis de conclure un empoisonnement
autre information notable cette fois en
provenance de biélorussie lors d'un
entretien organisé entre le premier
ministre russe michail michaud steen qui
s'est déplacé à minsk et a donc
rencontré alexandre lukashenko le
président biélorusse prétend avoir en sa
possession des preuves et plus
précisément un enregistrement qui
mettraient en doute les déclarations
d'hier les déclarations du gouvernement
allemand sur l'empoisonnement d'alexei
navalni écoutait la chancelière
allemande a déclaré que certains
voulaient clouer le bec de
valny et maintenant varsovie parle avec
berlin nous allons tout préparer et
envoyer au fsb
il y a deux interlocuteurs qui disent
clairement qu'il s'agit d'une
falsification
il n'y a eu aucun empoisonnement de
navalni un groupe de spécialistes
d'après ce que je comprends à préparer
des faits pour merkel pour
l'administration allemande et peut-être
également la déclaration qu'elle a
réalisé ils ont agi ainsi pour je cite
apprendre à poutine à ne pas mettre son
nez dans les affaires de la biélorussie
fin de citation vous voyez à quel point
ces gens sont jésuites une information à
laquelle les autorités russes n'ont pas
encore réagi n'ayant pas leur
disposition l'ensemble des éléments mais
le kremlin a rappelé à toutes fins
utiles être déterminé à faire toute la
lumière sur cette affaire
antoine claireaux en direct de moscou
merci pour cette précision